But if you don't heal that gut barrier, you're never going to win.
So one of the major things that damage your gut barrier, well, the most common thing that
damages your gut barrier today, unfortunately, is something you can't run away from anymore.
It's GMO foods.
So GMO cord, one of the benefits of it, is it's more resistant to cord moors, those little
bugs that get on cord and eat the cord stock and diminish the harvest for the farmer.
You know how it is resistant to cord moors?
It eats their gut.
So the chemical that's put in GMO cord destroys the gut in the cord moor.
So it's more resistant.
They don't like GMO cord.
So what is it doing to our gut when it is 60% of your food contains some source of cord
that's GMO cord.
So you guys should be up in the arms, again, genetically modified foods, because it's very
damaged into your gut, and that's one of the main theories on why autoimmune diseases
just rampied up the last 10 years.